[Music]
[Music]
we're just a few weeks away from the nfl
draft and we know you got we got you
covered here on crash course live in the
bleacher report app every thursday at 1
pm i'm the lead nfl draft analyst here
at bleacher report connor rogers joined
as always by stadium's college football
analyst michael felder we got a loaded
show today we're going to get right into
this wide receiver tight end breakdown
we're gonna talk about the trade that
shook up the first round this week
between the eagles and the saints and
our divisional preview this week is the
nfc west the ever very competitive nfc
west so see the player comparisons here
for the wide receivers belder we're
gonna be jacked up today man this is one
of the best shows of the year as as it
is another loaded pass catching class
yeah no i love that we kick it off with
the player comps we're not wasting time
folks we are not wasting time so if
you're joining us watching it you get
those player cops we got more player
comps we got outdated player comps
apparently that we are still going to
slide into the show but
we get to talk about the prospects and
conor as we
we go from player comps to people
getting to see me and all my the beard
glory on screen let's get to let's get
to the blue chip prospects because there
are so many players to fit in that i
have a separate list of guys that we
couldn't even include because there were
so many players
yeah we had to trim uh i wouldn't even
call it the fat on this felder we had to
trim some of the prime off of this
that's how loaded this group is but
let's start with jameson williams right
one of the most explosive players in
this entire draft
somebody that really reminds me of what
mike wallace was for the steelers for a
long time just an explosive deep threat
that truly cannot be covered you can
play 10 yards off him and he can still
run by you so for jameson williams we
know he's dealing with the injury but if
you're looking for speed and nfl
offenses are always looking for speed
this is the guy felder if you could just
be a little patient with his rehab
that'll probably have him ready to go
maybe about halfway into the season or a
quarter into the season
yeah i love the nuance to his game you
see there the little stem inside he
pulls everybody in thinking that he's
going to run some sort of a dig then
he's able to out sprint them to the post
i love that i love the nuance to his
game the small things that he does
really really well so i think there's
that um listen we also have to talk
about garrett wilson garrett wilson's
another player who is absolutely just i
mean not only is he exploding like he
doesn't have to explode up draft boards
this guy's been an elite player for the
whole time so when we look at garrett
wilson another guy that does small
things really well but i also think just
the speed and the nimbleness that he has
make him an interesting prospect
yeah i think so too he's really in the
mold of a calvin ridley where he's
coming out into the nfl and he's a
polished route runner that knows how to
separate immediately but it's all three
phases you see right here what he can do
with the ball in his hands that ability
to get up field with vertical speed
especially after the catch slippery can
make you miss can make you look foolish
so for garrett wilson he is plug and
play truly you can't say that about a
lot of these wide receivers we know
jameson's dealing with an injury drake
london's dealing with an injury some of
them are still figuring out their route
running for garrett wilson he's coming
onto the field he can be your high end
number two instantly that's about as big
of praise as you can give someone and
he's gonna be a top 15 pick but felder
let's take it to drake london who has
been dealing with an injury for a long
time season ending in october with the
ankle has not been able to test yet but
this is a jump ball above the rim
bully felder he is the true definition
of a small forward out there playing
wide receiver and he just exploded for
the first two months in the pac-12 this
year
yeah he was he was remarkable and and
this is something that i think about a
lot we talk about basketball players
converting to tight end a lot obviously
with guys like jimmy graham or antonio
gates but we don't talk nearly enough
about guys like
guys like obviously randy moss started
this trend where basketball players are
like oh i'm not going to be this
position in college i can do this on the
football field and guys can't stop me
and drake london is one of those guys
that he's got that moss quality i'm not
comparing him to randy moss that's not
what i'm doing what i am saying is
these guys who are used to playing as
you mentioned above the rim he's used to
doing that and i think a lot of times
football players guys who are lifelong
football players only they're used to
catching the ball in their bread basket
right they're using the ball being here
and he's used to catching going up and
getting it and i love his ability to go
up and get it his ability to catch the
ball out and away from his body is what
i find to be remarkable and you know
what connor i'm gonna
i really like this next player i am
going to give you the floor
for traelin burks because he you you
single you got him on the blue chips
list
man we're unified in this one felder you
love trailing burks just as much as me
this is a pro trailing berks show he is
a
a tough guy that makes it happen with
the ball in his hands a lot of people
have looked at trailing burks and said
can he be devos samuel and i think he's
a little bit different of a player you
see him on the outside here covered but
guess what i'm going to take the ball
away but when you look at the ability
and to just catch the ball and make
things happen on the run be that big
above the rim threat kind of like drake
london in the red zone but not like
drake london in between the 20s and you
see the vertical speed over the top
traelin burks physically is on a
different planet than any wide receiver
in the strap class and when you look at
the nfl combine for him people look at
it and maybe they're disappointed he ran
a four five five a four five five at
almost 230 pounds is a train rolling
down the tracks it's not a five foot ten
guy running in the four threes or a four
four this is grown man breakaway speed
it's on tape and heat felder i don't
even want to call him a wide receiver he
is the definition of offensive weapon
he's a he's a football player that's
what i call like he's a football player
he'll do whatever his team needs he will
take a handoff he'll take a jet sweep
he'll do the whole deal i love that
about him so that's our blue chip guys i
know we want to talk technicians look
we've talked enough chris olave that we
don't have to bring him up again crystal
lobby is
squarely in the technician camp i think
kyle phillips from ucla fits in that as
well so as we transition into the
technicians
conor let's kick it off with a guy that
we haven't really talked about on the
show khalil shakir from boise state
because he is someone that watching him
play
it seems like every part of his game is
so measured so precise
that even and again even though
he's not the fastest guy it doesn't
matter he understands that if i got to
get to 12 on this on this curl i need to
get this guy up to 14 so that i have
space or he gives himself space to the
sideline he does all these little things
right
he really does felder and i love that we
got him here in the technician phase
because when you watch him play that's
how he wins right he understands how to
get open he understands how to get off
the line of scrimmage with footwork he
understands once the ball is in my hands
i'm going to get up field and make a
play so for shakir he's somebody that
yeah he's not the biggest guy he's got a
short catch radius but he just finds a
way to get it done works through traffic
at an excellent level and he's gonna be
one of those maybe round four kind of
picks that when you look two to three
years down the road like oh he's our
long-term number three wide receiver uh
because we love his demeanor we love how
polished he is let's take a quick break
from the technicians and jump into the
comment section because it's been
jumping off about the wide receiver
class moose maxwell back in the comments
says how do the ohio state wide
receivers this year compared to other
ohio state wide receivers in the past
are they better than michael thomas and
tara mclaren for me felder i think
they're different than a michael thomas
who it was more of that middle of the
field gonna beat you with physicality
kind of player where i look at terry
mclaren and even a garrett wilson
crystal lava
they're kind of all together in the
smooth operator i know how to get open
mold you're not going to be able to
press me at the line of scrimmage and i
can beat you in the intermediate range
so
felder i think this is there are some
similarities there but there also are
some differences with the buckeyes
yeah i think that ultimately in in no
disrespect to mclaren but i think that
what we're seeing are more polished
prospects at the wide receiver position
right like with thomas coming out he was
a guy that it still felt very raw even
though we knew he was good it felt more
raw these guys are polished these guys
run these routes the route tree has been
enhanced increased if you will at ohio
state and the the and look we're looking
at a school that has decided we're gonna
we're gonna
put our eggs in this this wide receiver
basket this is what we're gonna do and
they decide listen you're gonna learn
how to run this route you're gonna know
how to run the right way and that's why
olave obviously fits into the technician
that's why garrett wilson if he wasn't
as fast as he was and he wasn't just a
guy that we expect to be what a top 12
top 15 pick if he wasn't that he'd be in
the technician group as well probably
because he does all those little things
well and he's really great with the ball
in his hand so i think they've really
grown as a wide receiving group and
that's a testament to what a day's
really been pushing there uh for the
buckeyes
yeah absolutely back in the comments
section they are joining us on the
trailing berks love soggy says the best
wide receiver in this draft is t burks
shaw bryan says burke can be more
similar to antwon bolden that's a fun
comp what's even crazier is
burks is even faster what do you think
of that comparison felder i see your
eyes light up at that one
listen anquan boldin look you heard what
i said when we talked about berks right
i said he's a football player first in a
wide receiver second
anquan bolden is the definition of that
this is a guy that got his entire face
broken and said don't worry about me i'm
still playing football and
he he's a boldin is a football player
first burks is a football player first i
love that comp i think that
berks probably has a little bit more
long game than bolden
but i think both of them are guys that
listen as a former safety
not thrilled about trying to tackle this
guy
i love it all right back to the
technicians here we started with khalil
shakur let's take it to john metchi
obviously another player that had to
deal with the season-ending injury that
has hurt his process a little bit once
upon a time mechi viewed as at least a
top 50 pick maybe even a sneaky first
rounder it's probably looking closer to
round three from mechi right now but
felder i look at him watch the tape
watch the smoothness in the route
running love the short area quick
reminds me of emmanuel sanders a little
bit with meche he's going to come in and
you kind of nailed this and this has
been a theme with our ohio state and
alabama wide receivers they are guys
that understand how to get open in the
intermediate area of the field and with
a quick passing game that is going to
translate right away so what have you
seen from mechy so far as you see him
laying a monster hit after an
interception there was not ready for
that one on the b-roll but i love it
well he's a gamer like listen he he look
we saw the bang on the interception he's
like listen i'm gonna do my job to make
sure we still find a way to win so i
love that part of his game but the other
part is he's deliberate and he's precise
and i that the big thing for me and the
play against auburn that we if we could
re-rack that b-roll just to show the
play against auburn would be lovely
because he knows when he's supposed to
come open and i think that's the most
awesome part of what mechi does he
understands i got to get this guy to
open his hips i got to get this guy to
widen out by two yards and then i can
bang it back inside and here it is right
here look i got to get this guy to open
now i'm open guess what we can win this
football game and i think that's the
cool thing about what he does he
understands when to sit when to keep
running he knows all those things so
thank you guys for showing that again
because in that that's a game and let's
remember
that's game on the line against auburn
that's game on the line national
championship possibility on the line
against auburn
it's amazing to see a guy still be that
measured that composed you mentioned um
you mentioned somebody coming in being
an early number two wide receiver i
think he comes in he's your early like
this guy he's
he hunter renfro right
this guy can do those same things he
understands the little parts of the game
little football's a game of inches and
people don't realize that it's a game of
steps
if you take one bad step and he can make
you make that one bad step then he can
get back inside on you and guess what
now we have a first down which means we
extend our drive which gives us an
opportunity to store and that's what i
love about meche which is why he fits
squarely in the technician zone and i'll
go to the next guy because this is an
interesting one i saw the comp that you
had who who did you have as a cop for
david bell connor
yeah let's fire it up one more time here
we got the player comps david bell we
are looking at wait wait wait for it
we are still searching jacoby myers come
on down here felder jacoby myers these
are guys that
they don't test well they might not be
six foot five
but they just go out and get it done
felder at the catch point they don't
need a ton of space to win you see the
shiftiness there on the field he's not
explosive he's not gonna go out there
and run a 4-4
a lot of guys these guys don't pass
thresholds for athleticism but there's
something different on the field it's
the awareness something you always talk
about felder and you just talked about
it with meche as a former db that's
something you analyze extremely well
better than anyone i've ever worked with
spacing on the field understanding how
to create your spacing understanding
that you can't gravitate to the sideline
you need to open up the corner of the
end zone you need to be a zone beater
you need to find ways to do that all
three of our technicians shakur mechi
who didn't get to test david bell who
did not test well he actually tested
really poorly they do those things on
tape that translate to production on the
football field
yeah i love david bell and i know we're
going to go to the comments here in a
section in a sec in a second uh but this
section i wanted to hit on because david
bell is someone a little bit like dj
moore and dj more obviously probably
tested he tested better than david bell
but two guys that they're not as tall as
you want them to be
and but the technical part of their game
is not just route running which we
talked about with shakira which you
talked about with metchy the technical
part of their game is also
ball tracking ball attacking and
understanding when they're open and when
to be open i think that's something that
needs to be mentioned because so often
we talk about long speed and i know
we're going to get to burners later but
i love the fact that we talk about a guy
who i mean we watch it on the clips he
attacks the football and that is
technical work as a football player so i
wanted to do that before we get to the
comics
all right the comments street scout says
who is a guy who will be drafted after
the start of round four
that has wide receiver one tools felder
do you have a sleeper for me uh that's a
that's a pretty late round area for
there but has wide receiver one tools i
think of somebody like
maybe an isaiah weston maybe a jalen
tolbert from south alabama although i
think he can go in the first three
rounds is there anybody that you like in
that category builder well that's the
thing that's a it's a little late
because i was gonna say romeo dubs if
we're talking about maybe an early day
three guy but if we're talking round
four i think dubs goes in that third
round probably right like end of the
second i know we're going to talk about
it when we get to burners anyways but
he's he's probably a end of the second
day early first early third day guy and
so
it's i it's it's hard to find those guys
it's hard to find guys that are day
three guys
mid to late day three guys with
early
like with first receiver traits i think
it's a lot easier especially with the
the proliferation of the spread and the
way that college football has kind of
created this
wide receiver
every year wide receiver's probably
going to be the deepest position in the
draft from now until eternity
and so what you have are a lot of guys
that can be
your your slot receivers that can be
your third receivers that can be all
those things it's hard to find in number
one and i think teams are
realizing finding the number one is
critical because number one opens up
everything for your two threes your
tight ends and everything else
all right i see a comment section uh a
comment saying that mechi's faster than
emmanuel sanders emmanuel sanders ran a
4-4 at the at the combine so i think
that's right around where mitch he'll be
if he ran the four threes of healthy
better for him back to that question
felder you're right it's hard to narrow
a guy down like that uh if the audience
has not seen isaiah weston yet northern
iowa wide receiver he will not be on our
breakdown today but six foot three and a
half 215 pounds four four speed 40 inch
vertical no polish there he's just out
athleting everybody on the field he will
be a day three pick as well so let's get
back into the breakdown and we'll go
back to the comments after burners
this is one of the most exciting
sections on the entire show felder
because these are the guys that just
beat you with speed they light up the
track a lot of them no coincidence are
track guys first and then became
excellent football players let's start
with danny gray a texas guy i believe a
former hundred meter state champion so
you're talking about legitimate speed
goes to smu and man felder he can beat
you deep but they schemed a lot of short
touches to him as you see the drag rat
right here the crosser
where they just go we're gonna dump the
ball in your hands and you're gonna fly
up the field and we talk about it on the
show all the time how horizontal the nfl
has become
danny gray is going to find a home for a
similar role at the next level
yeah 4-3-3
i mean 4-3-3 come on let's go
it's insane and you watch the clips here
and you see there's nobody close to him
he's running away from everyone so i i
think the key
if you're the team that drafts danny
gray the key is to find him easy catches
and that's the that's the huge part here
when we talk about the technicians when
we talk about the blue chip guys hard
catches are what they do really well
that's what they like david bell's
someone that's going to make a contested
catch the thing that you have to do is
get danny gray the ball in space find a
way to give him a long handoff and then
after that nobody can run with him so i
think that's going to be really
interesting to see where he where he
gets picked but also how they use him
because the key is going to be and i
think about this a lot with james cook
as well as just just get him the ball in
a place where he has five yards around
him to operate
and then you're gonna get to see the
brilliance that is danny gray
yeah let him grab the engine a little
bit and get downhill and good luck for
anybody trying to catch that ferrari all
right moving on to romeo dubs i believe
you mentioned him earlier in the show
felder as that potential day three guy
that can be a star but we do have the
feeling he can go in round three you see
the projection right there he reminds me
of darius sleightenfelder somebody that
at auburn they weren't able to always
push the ball vertically to he ends up
in the new york giants as a late pick
and finds a lot of early production and
i think with dubs you don't have to
worry about that because at nevada they
threw the football carson strong has a
big time arm and you see the clips with
dubs here running the vertical routes
and he just has the ability to win down
the field now with doves he's somebody
that
went to the senior bowl had some
production obviously had a good career
at nevada he is a true send him
vertically down the field i think you
can work the screens to him like gray
but he's got a little bit of a longer
body type than danny gray so what have
you seen with dubsfelder before we move
to our next wide receiver which i know
are both excited to break down in the
burners category
so there's two things that i love about
this kid one you know he returns punts
right
that's crazy oh yeah that's your team's
a tippy that body to be that body type
and return punts that doesn't happen
very often number two
is i love the way that he plays through
contact so yes i do love him as an
over-the-top threat i love his ability
to get down the field and make plays but
my favorite play for him is against i
believe it's kansas state where he is
pass interfered with but he continues to
run through contact and make a catch uh
at the goal line to try to get the ball
into the end zone not just looking for a
flag he's he this is a guy that has the
speed of a burner but the physicality of
someone like a michael irvin right like
someone like a like a calvin johnson
like i'm trying to think of names that
people think about when they think oh he
um
played for the cowboys went to oklahoma
state
dez bryant
dez bryant yes like that physicality to
play through contact and not just beg
for flags i love that about his game
just as much thank you for saving me on
that because i could not think of his
name the next thing i was gonna say was
the guy that came up one yard short of
the end zone and tried to put the ball
in like i was i couldn't come up with it
but i love that about doves i think that
he is his willingness to play through
contact is really important and i love
that about him um let's get to calvin
austin too because
you want to talk about fast man
he runs
right checking the board 432 40
out of memphis
and it's everything felder the four four
four three two forty the six six five
three cone the 39 inch vertical
just a super athlete now at five eight
you know 175 pounds that at that weight
he'll play at
you gotta move like that but fortunately
for him he does goes to memphis as a
track guy obviously carves out a
football role as a super super stud
playmaker goes back to your point about
dubs with austin no surprise with him
that smaller body type excellent punt
returner but excellent wide receiver
that's not just a gadget guy he can get
down the fields he can win on
intermediate routes love what he can do
in the middle of the field knows how to
get off the line of scrimmage with the
quicks a smaller guy that if you try to
press him he's too fast and you see the
player comparison there marquise goodwin
no surprise a track guy track guy
comparison calvin austin uh just tested
off the charts and because of that he's
gonna go early in this draft potentially
in the top 75 picks let's dive into the
comments to see what they think of the
burner section so far we've got a lot
going on here david shepard says jahan
dotson getting slept on here felder well
i think jahan dotson we've talked about
a lot on this show but go ahead
we've talked listen if i was going to
put them anywhere i'd put them in the
technician category we've already talked
about johan dotson multiple shows he's
not being slept on same thing with chris
o'lave we're trying to the goal of this
show is to it's a draft crash course if
we go over the same material every
single week you're not learning anything
so we're trying to give you some new
names some new guys that we haven't
talked about nearly as nearly as much so
yes we love johan dotson this is a a pro
jahaan datsun show we love him he is
amazing i think if you can't get olava
you get datsun and you're going to be
very happy
austin clark in the comments section
beau melton from rutgers is nice too i
love that one beau melton is going to be
a slot for a long time another guy that
tested well and was held back by an
abysmal rucker's offense but beau melton
can play there's no denying that all
right
wild card section we did the blue chips
we did the technicians we did the
burners
these guys are a little bit of could
become stars
could be low floor players there's a lot
of projecting here
but man let's start with one that might
hear his name in the first round of this
draft in breakout year at north dakota
state an excellent senior bowl and then
felder i mean he just tests like an
alien unlike anything we've ever seen
this is christian watson from north
dakota state he is in rare territory
with the kind of athlete he is here
felder now the question is will that
translate to the fields right away or is
he going to need a little time to
marinate
well i think the interesting thing and
obviously we think about it uh with guys
that are going up two levels right it's
not just him going up to
uh the the fbs level it's him going up
from fcs going to the nfl so he's
jumping two levels it's like going from
high school to it's really tough and not
not going from high school to the pros
but going from high school to the to the
fps level is hard because you're jumping
up an extra level and he's going to be
going up two levels as well so i think
the interesting part here is going to be
uh is he ready to to put those skills to
use is he ready for the competition
that's the interesting element the
testing is great obviously him against
uh other competition is going to be the
interesting element here how do you
think he fares when he takes that that
that double step up from the fcs to the
nfl
i think the play strength needs to get a
little better here felder right we could
sit here and talk about how you know
great he looks on the track all the 90
percentile measurables the one four six
ten yards split that acceleration that's
all there and i thought the route
running at the senior bowl looked really
really good for a guy that's never had
that thousand yard season and it's not
necessarily his fault we know what north
dakota state likes to do on offense they
are going to be run heavy they're going
to be smash mouth he's asked to block a
lot but i think felder when i look at
somebody that's over six foot foot four
over 205 pounds i would like to see you
constantly bully dbs at the fcs level
and i think that's something that we
haven't seen consistently from christian
watson yet and it's why i don't think he
needs and you see it from alonzo soto
christian watson seems unreal i don't
think he needs a red shirt here i just
think if you're expecting him to come in
and be jamar chase or this number one
kind of target you're going to be a
little disappointed it's going to take
some time
yeah i think you're spot on i think that
has to do with
you're supposed to be if you're if
you're going to come in and beat your
marches you're supposed to be dominant
which jamar chase was at his level and
that you're supposed to be physically
dominant when you're talking to fcs um
the other guy i know we want to get to
uh what was it western michigan sky
moore i have another player i know you
like do you think skye moore sneaks into
that first day or is he an early day two
guy
i think you're looking at him around 34
to the lions and then you take it from
there and yes he is under five foot ten
yes he is under 200 pounds but ten and a
quarter inch hands there felder and they
snag everything i mean one of the more
productive wide receivers in college
football not just this you know calvin
austin romeo dubs player that they just
sent on go routes they use them all over
the place and you see the ability to
work over the middle of the field to
catch and run with no hesitation that's
an underrated skill set the ability to
take the ball and keep going i know it's
something you talk about a lot there
felder so for skye moore i don't think
just because of his size he's projected
as this inside wide receiver i think he
has the quicks to play outside he's
shown he can get open from the outside
and i think because of that he's a
bonafide top 50 pick right now you see
the player comparison right there to
pierre garcon
i i love that pierre garcon comparison
man i haven't thought about pierre in a
minute dude that's a good one i like
that they didn't make me change that one
i dig that one um i'm gonna go with the
last guy our last wild card uh uh george
pickens uh coming off the injury
obviously lack of productivity question
how he was used in college um
george pickens what do you think about
this guy because i think he's he ha he
can be excellent it's just a matter of
if you let him be great
felder this is why we made the wild card
section right there is no bigger wild
card in this draft than george pickens
when you look at it he is mr checks
every box right he has spectacular plays
he has size he has speed uh he blocks
tail off oh my goodness he blocks his
tail off this guy is a street fighter
right and i really mean that in the best
possible way he comes up and he will
punch you in the mouth he will throw you
out of bounds he'll do everything he
takes he loves the street fight on the
field the question here is felder he's
been hurt and guys get hurt torn acls
happen right it's that's you're not
going to hold that against a guy in
terms of completely knocking him down
but the question for me is with pickens
right now is
why were you not the randy moss of this
offense are we going to blame that on
george's quarterback player are we going
to blame that on that they have the best
one of the best defenses we've ever seen
and they can just run the ball and slow
play games with george pickens he is the
classic case of could this guy be more
productive in an nfl offense if you put
george pickens with aaron rodgers or
with patrick mahomes or with justin
herbert where he can stretch the field
vertically and that ball comes his way
more often you might have a superstar
and i know you've been you've been with
me felder he's that case of
what is he right now and what can he
become
yeah i i just think he was completely
underused misused and some combination
of obviously stetson bennett i've been
able to push the ball vertically down
the field kirby smart being incredibly
conservative offensively not wanting to
take risks especially when you have the
best defense in the country so just
underused so he becomes undervalued he
has a better nfl career i'll put it on
this he'll have a better nfl career than
he had a college career and you know
what he's not going to be upset about it
because it's way easier to count money
and so i love that form another wild
card i'll throw in there before we go to
the condense what the comments wandel
robinson what do you think about him and
then take us to the comments
the most fascinating gadget player in
the draft and that's not even an insult
to wandel it's more of this is a league
that just loves to manufacture touches
to play makers and those guys are
fitting in better because of that the
jet sweeps the pitch passes the bubble
screens the you know leak out kind of
play for wandale where how do we find a
way to get the ball in his hand so he
can make five guys miss and i think that
is something that'll be his calling card
he is a very athletic player i had him
as a rondelle moore type without that
elite athleticism but more of can we use
him the same way so wandel robinson
somebody i'm glad you got in on the show
the comments are jumping off of course
moose maxwell says skye moore gives me
antonio brown vibes big big compliment
there for skye moore thanos jr says and
i love this comment george pickens is a
guy whose scheme didn't really allow for
the best of his abilities but i think he
can excel at the next level felder and i
obviously agree with you and then lima
lion says pickens looks fire but the
injury concerns me the same with drake
london that's going to be a giant wild
card we don't get access to what the
medicals look like but the nfl draft
often tells you what those look like so
felder loaded wide receiver group if
there's somebody we didn't go over today
it's most likely because we've had them
on a previous show or we'll have them on
a future show i think 30 wide receivers
can be taken in the strap let's move on
to the tight ends and i think we're
going to break this down in two
different ways the pass catchers and the
traditional inline guys you see some
player comps right here and we're going
to start with that first guy right there
trey mcbride who was
the focal point of an offense felder
that is something you don't hear every
day a college tight end being the focal
point of his offense
yeah do you think a guy that caught 90
passes maybe is a pass catching tight in
it was remarkable like going through the
tape and being like oh and it's him
again and then it's him again you know
it's him again and
oh he's doing it again and then he has a
couple rushers as well including a a
fake punt for a touchdown so this is a
guy that yeah they lined him flexed out
he can play an f he can play an h you
can play a y he can do all those things
you see the one hand snag there against
the aztecs he can get the job done
mcbride is certainly someone who comes
in
with the pedigree to to
get himself open
and go make catches he's
i don't think he's as athletic as
someone like in evan ingram when ingram
was coming out but he certainly has the
know-how when it comes to pass catching
to always find himself open and he's
he's an advanced version if you will
like if if heath miller is you know
you're taking regular classes in high
school uh mcbride as a pass catcher is
he's taking ap classes that's what he
does this guy's got the ability to do
everything in the passing game yeah i
think he's got the best hands in the
draft and i really mean that and we saw
him out in the monsoon rain at the
senior bowl he catches everything he
doesn't need to be open to catch the
ball you see the player comparison right
there he is not as big as mark andrews
but he can have the same impact as a
pass catcher in an offense that wants to
be 12 personnel they always want two
tight ends on the field and one is going
to be trusted to handle the route
running
in that short to intermediate area so
a guy in a very different mode we've
seen mcbride succeed in line we can see
him hold his own as a blocker but is a
great pass catcher greg dolcich from
ucla is all past catching felder he is
high cut he is a seam threat he is a run
and catch threat he's not going to give
you much as a blocker you're not going
to ask him to play on the line of
scrimmage but what he does do is make
plays as a bigger wide receiver
right but the thing is is he forces a
linebacker into the football game right
like that's like when we you push away
all the value of what he can do in terms
of finding a way to get open outrunning
people the key for me is he forces a
linebacker into the football game and
forcing that linebacker into the fourth
into the football game means that you
have numbers in the pass game and so
when you think about that whether it's
12 or 11 you play 11 with greg dolcich
that team knows that they still have to
have another linebacker in the game to
account for him and you play 12 with him
you got to have that extra linebacker in
there to account for him and the other
tight end and that's the element or if
you have a play 21 and you have two
running backs one one tight end you have
to account for that with an extra
linebacker and then he makes you pay by
flexing out and being and being able to
outrun i will say this i don't care who
drafts him
you better have the sneak play in there
where you have two wide receivers with
him flexed out in wide trips so that
those two wide receivers can run double
post and then he can sneak out of the
backfield to run up the sideline because
that play is a killer to ask someone in
man coverage to get there if you're a
linebacker if you're a big nickel to
cover him up the field you're in trouble
so put that play in your playbook
because it is special
yeah too fast for linebackers
too big for most dbs unless you got you
know kyle hamilton out there you're
going to be in trouble so dulcet's
definitely a mismatch weapon let's round
out the pass catching tight ends before
we move to the traditional inline
players charlie kohler felder pretty
productive at the college level for a
long time he's been banged up on and off
but
for me i look at him and i see tyler
higbee that six foot six giant catch
radius enough athleticism where it goes
back to finding mismatch plays and you
see the route running there and the db
holding on for dear life but no i'll
still be able to bully you catch the
ball one-handed and make something
happen kohler can stretch the field a
little bit and at that size you don't
need to be two or three steps ahead of a
guy right there you see it really a half
step win on the route but i'm bigger i
have a big catch radius and the tracking
right there and for kohler i'll say this
the name of the game for him is going to
be pass catching first and second but
there were times they trusted him in
line to do enough as a blocker maybe cut
off guys maybe move him as an outside
zone blocker a little bit so for kohler
maybe with one of the most slept on
players in this entire draft at this
point
well i think he slept on because iowa
state started out as a top 10 team and
then kind of had a massive falling off
and so we see that happen all the time
in the draft where guys who are still
good still productive if their team
doesn't win you start to forget about
them and i think kohler's a victim of
that as well same thing we talked about
a week ago right with bruce hall so i
look at him and he's lean but he's not
small he is
capable like he's bigger than a guy like
a grant calcutta who we talked about a
week ago he's still got some physicality
to his game the ability to play in line
uh the thing i love about what he brings
to the table
is that little bit of fight that little
bit of bite the ability to as you we saw
in that first clip
arm bar a guy and still catch a football
so kohler yeah i love that this is
completing our kind of pantheon of our
top three pass catching tight ends as we
move on to the traditional guys or
actually you know are we going to the
comments we're going to the comments
let's go to the comments yeah we'll dive
into the comments here felder sounds
savvy says mcbride looks like he's ready
for tight end university daddy's suit
says mcbride reminds me a lot of george
kittle felder this one's for you pete
rodriguez jelani woods will be a better
pro than what he showed us in college
listen jelani woods is on my board as
one of the guys that we might not have
talked about but we got to get to him
this guy's a freak like he's an absolute
monster he's the size of someone that
should be playing in the nba
watching him out there running around
was just like what who can do anything
with them i think virginia they used him
but didn't use him nearly enough like i
listen if he got as many targets as
mcbride this guy would be it would be
insane so i i really love jelani woods
huge guy i think that certainly he's
someone connor where do you see him
going is he a day two guy is he an early
day three gun
he has put himself firmly in day two
felder they just don't come around at
six foot seven and run like jelani woods
and yes leverage blocking is going to
take a little while to get used to for
him it's it's not going to be easy when
you're a skyscraper and you have to
block these he's figuring it out he
figured it out he figured a lot of he's
gotten a lot better he's gotten a lot
better blocking where went from
developmental to
good enough and gonna get a lot better
but when you put that guy up to see him
at six foot seven nobody wants to hit
him nobody can run with him that's big
enough to run with him so jelani woods
he's had one hell of a process and he's
put himself as a maybe a top five tight
end off the board in this draft all
right we're gonna get to the traditional
guys here and these are two of my
favorites let's start with jeremy rucker
from ohio state we've talked about him
on the show a little bit but now it's
the jeremy rucker spotlight right here
for ohio state maybe not the most
productive guy they didn't ask him to be
you said it earlier this is a school
that recruits eight million five-star
wide receivers and they get them from
everywhere not just up in the midwest
they've gone down to texas and gotten
garrett wilson before when you look at
jeremy rucker i got to see him in person
this year felder incredible blocker on
the move a total tough guy a wipeout
blocker huge catch radius in the red
zone i see hunter henry when i watch him
play hunter henry is has been one of the
more reliable tight ends in the last
couple years of the nfl rucker is the
classic case we trust him in line we
trust them over the middle of the field
work them to the corners in the red zone
and you see the excellent hands and
tracking right there
yeah great ball tracker great ability to
find himself open you see him there with
the stop to go back to catch the
football i love that part of his game
obviously the the big catch in the back
of the end zone uh in the big 10
championship game he he does all these
little things very well he does the he
he plays the position the way that
traditionalists want the position to be
played he is a blocker he will block he
will go an entire game blocking the
entire game if that's what you want to
do i'll do it but he is someone that
it's
it's very greg olseny for me i know that
you you had a different comp but the
greg olsen one for me is like
a classic tight end who also if you are
going to feed him and he's going to be
the target guy he's going to deliver for
you because he just he does everything
right
you know what and he's he's done
everything right for a long stretch of
time he's not one of these flash in the
pan one year wonders he went back to
school and last year he would have been
a third round pick and that kind of
surprised me and he went back and i
think he's played himself into you know
throughout the entire process not just
the senior bowl but really everything
that he's done on tape for a long time
as well
he's played himself into a early third
round maybe late second round kind of
player that is once again one of the
rare he can come in and start right away
so the comments uh they're all over
felder i think the comment section is
it's very smart i'll say that they are
all over this draft you could tell
they've been joining us for weeks having
fun getting to know this throwing their
player comps in there thanos jr says
jake ferguson was ultra reliable in that
wisconsin offense that is right thanos
jake ferguson four years in a row with
30 plus catches felder take it away it's
time for jake ferguson
yeah honestly like the big thing and we
did this on our pre-pro call right
what's the difference between rucker and
ferguson what's the real difference
ferguson more more targets but both of
these guys
they can play in line they'll catch
everything you throw to them i love jake
ferguson i think this is a guy listen if
you can't get rucker get ferguson and
it's it's
he's so good at all the small things you
see if they're the one hand catch he's
got a great catch radius he's got some
explosiveness to his game he's going to
be in for me when i think about a tight
end i think about a true
third receiver essentially right a third
pass catcher if you will because if
you've got one outside two inside then
you get to your tight end on play side
now we're looking at a guy who's the
third option which means he's either
being covered by a safety who has to
come down or he's covered by a
linebacker and if he's covered by a
linebacker he's too fast for that if
he's covered by safety he's too big for
that and he brings this that to the
table and i think the key for me with
ferguson is
he did it all the time when everyone
knew he was going to get the ball at
wisconsin like where do you where does
that rank for you connor when teams know
they know that he's gonna get the ball
and he they still found a way to get the
ball he still found a way to catch him
it's huge it's consistency it's we can
trust you week in and week out and we
just saw the cowboys franchise tag
dalton schultz at a big number jake
ferguson's the same exact guy he's the
same exact body type the same exact
athleticism the same hands the same
blocking and back to your rucker versus
ferguson i think it's pretty simple i
think ferguson is a better more reliable
blocker right now while rucker is a
little bit better of an athlete i think
he's gonna he runs a little better i
think he can give you a little bit more
in the past catching but ferguson's a
reliability from that 7 to 12 yard range
uh is incredible all right let's get
back into the comments they're popping
off about the tight ends c brown 29 says
rucker and kohler are complete tight
ends see brown said record is the next
jeremy shockey belder we're going to
sneak this one in before we talk about
the big trade this week s cole says how
high does jalen why to meyer go
it's like people are reading my board my
little board over here i got weidemeyer
on there so yeah i just i think that
watermelon is an interesting prospect
because we've seen him be productive in
the passing game we've seen him work to
get better in the blocking game
i mean listen connor you're the expert
on i like him as a player i think he was
one of the better tight ends in the sec
this year but where does he fit in this
year's nfl drive
man he's one of the most interesting
prospects in the entire draft for me
because there are times where he makes
incredible catches there are times where
he drops the easiest throws and you look
at the body type you look at the
capability as a blocker the build
ability to play in line move them off
the line and everything right there was
early third round selection felder i
don't understand what happened to this
guy at the pro day i mean he runs a 502
which is one of the worst 40 times i've
seen for a tight end while doing this
the vertical's 25 inches all the testing
metrics are
what teams would consider undraftable
but you turn on the tape and what he did
in the scc and i thought he was a top
five tight end in this entire draft so
how do you balance that because there
and you see him he is a little bit of a
slow moving lumbering guy but when
you're that big you can shield defenders
and take away the ball so
this one is perplexing to me felder
because we've never seen a tight end
with his lack of athleticism
translate and true have true success at
the next level but the tape is all right
there that says at a minimum he can
compete for a third or even second tight
end roll
well i think that the thing for me is
the question becomes what has he been
doing
and that's that's hard that's
interesting to me about the draft people
don't think about that nearly enough but
like what has he been doing because we
see it all on film but when the film
doesn't line up with what you're seeing
in on a pro day you got to ask what he's
been doing and the the bad part of that
is has he not been preparing for the
biggest job interview that he's ever
going to have because if you're not
preparing for the biggest job interview
you're ever going to have can i count on
you on a weekend week out basis in the
nfl so that's my take on it is we know
that he plays faster than a 502 we know
that he is more explosive than just
jumping what a 25 we know he's done all
those things better so what happened in
the meantime
that made him
that that made these numbers what they
are and that's that's the rough part and
that's the part that often goes under
discuss or undiscussed when it comes to
the nfl drop
all right let's take a look at the
offseason news of the week this draft
order changes on us every single week it
feels like there have been big trades
impacting the first round and none
bigger than this honestly right now
as the eagles traded picks 16 and 19
to the new orleans saints and in return
they're stacking for the futures now the
eagles have two first-rounders this year
and two first-rounders next year with a
little cherry on top that second-rounder
in 2024 but the saints now felder they
are we're picking 18th now they're
picking 16th and 19th so they get to
move up two spots from one pick and add
in another top 20 pick i have some
thoughts on how they can maneuver the
board and package these but felder if
they decided to stay in this spot is
there a scenario that makes sense for
the saints to double dip in this year's
first round after the big trade
yeah i'm a i'm a morris better guy i'm a
listen and it's not quantity over it's
not quantity over quality it's getting
two quality players instead of just the
one high quality player and so i look at
this and i think about someone like us
whether it's a zion johnson from boston
college and offensive tackle who's gonna
be able to help your football team uh
but i also think we know they need a
quarterback and the idea that they've
signed jameis winston to this two-year
deal but being able to get someone like
a desmond ritter who should be there
when they're picking whether it's 16 or
19 being able to get him and get ridder
and have him sit not have to have him
play not have to have him go out and be
your team savior not have them to go out
and be drew brees not have to go out and
be a superhero
but learn and play some package plays
play you know limited snaps play when
you're in a blowout win or lose get reps
in the nfl before you have to be the guy
i think that's great get your feet on
the ground and get adjusted to being in
the nfl and then guess what if he's if
he sits for a year and a half takes over
for jameis uh early in the early in year
two of jameis's new deal mid year two of
jameis's new deal guess what you got a
guy that understands new orleans you
also have him for uh three and a half
more years to decide if you want to keep
him or not so i think that's a good move
and then obviously we've talked about
the bc tackle that's just a great that's
a good pick it's just a good pick he's
going to be a guy that we saw go from
mid-second round he's bubbled his way up
to the back of the first round so i'm
i'm a two-for-one guy connor what are
you you like a two for one are you are
you packaging them and you're trying to
go you're going for the gold
i don't mind the two for one but let's
flip this upside down the comments are
going off about them going up for a
quarterback shaw brian says saints
moving up for willis thanos says saints
are going for a quarterback
i am following their trend of them going
up into the top ten with both these
picks the trade value equals out to
either the giants at five the jets at
four somewhere in between
but felder i think they believe in
jameis winston right now and they gave
him 21 million dollars guaranteed i
think i'd like him to start this year i
like your plan of drafting a quarterback
in the middle of the round and allows
them to develop at their own pace but if
they use these picks to go up we know
they lost to ron armstead to the miami
dolphins in free agency they have a huge
hole on the offensive line your idea of
zion johnson added to it i love it but
what if we think even bigger you go up
you use 16 and 19 and you get eben neal
a guy that could be your franchise left
tackle or franchise right tackle he's a
mammoth nobody carries 335 pounds on a
six foot seven body like this guy
whether it's the drive blocking in the
run game or the matching mirror pass
protection ability you see how quick he
is with those light feet those dancing
bare feet at six foot seven
i don't know felder there's just a gut
feeling with me that they have their
eyes on a big time prize in this trap
and that they might get this might have
been move number one of two to shake up
the first round
now it's going to be interesting to see
how it shakes out i think that obviously
listen if you're going to go to town you
might as well go into lincoln and so if
they're going to package this you might
as well get if you're going to make
these moves go up there be the biggest
boss you know on the block and go do it
so it's going to be interesting to see
how that works it also if you think
about the trades and the whole deal we
talked about we keep we constantly try
to reiterate that it changes the entire
complexion of the draft because
everybody behind you is affected by it
so if they're if they go up and snag
somebody like evan neal or even like a
iguanu
if they go up and do that then the next
thing you know everybody else is like
okay now we have to adjust our entire
board so they are
outside of what the jags and and they're
holding the keys to in the lions holding
the keys to a lot of what happens
and i would not be shocked to see
houston at number three maybe consider
getting out of that spot
they need the felder
quantity approach it's quality quantity
but they need a lot of players on that
53-man roster to turn things around all
right let's look at our divisional
breakdown of the week the nfc west one
of the most competitive divisions in
football you have the super bowl
champions los angeles rams you have the
niners who are always knocking on the
door of the super bowl arizona with
kyler murray they're always pretty close
and the seahawks in a really odd
transition state after trading russell
wilson so let's start with them as you
see their needs at the top of the board
here felder they did get drew locke back
but quarterback has to be in need they
lost bobby wagner so linebackers in need
offensive line they have not brought
back dwayne brown yet as well so they
have a lot of needs to see adult team
what are you looking at here to maybe
get this defense right or start to build
back the offense
well you know listen obviously you can
go offensive line and that's something
that will be interesting we just talked
about it with the saints and uh possibly
moving up to take one of these the one
of the like the guys that we have listed
as a blue chip so maybe at nine we're we
are looking at um uh cross being there
but i
it's nine too early for devonta wyatt
because i just watch more and more of
him and i love the way that he plays
and he's so explosive
he's so good with his hands he obviously
you see him there run to the sideline
after recognizing that he's gonna have
to play some contain i love that ability
i love his ability to do a little
cha-cha and then go make a play get his
hands up so i i don't know if nine's too
high for him i think he probably should
be one of the first defensive tackles
off the board just don't know if that
happens in the top ten the other guy i
throw on there though is chad mumma from
uh wyoming right they need linebackers
and i think he's incredible the question
i'd pose to you connor is where does he
go where does muma go
in this draft is he a day two guy is he
someone they can get on day three that's
going to help on special teams and then
grow into a bigger linebacker role
man they got picks 40 and 41 and felder
if they want him they need to take him
there because he's not making it to 72.
i think my sense with muma is you know
as much as teams like devin lloyd they
like nicoby dean they view muma as a
true middle of the defense i can take on
contact but i have enough juice to run
sideline to sideline and cover as well
and that three down skill set in today's
game is just too valuable so i think
muma with those back-to-back picks at 40
and 41 he's going in the top 50. that
could be the sweet spot for him let's
look at the cardinals here a variety of
different needs whether it's offensive
line help for kyler murray they do need
edge pass rush really really badly and
we'll see how they address tight end we
know zach ertz is getting a little older
they lost max williams to injury last
year we'll see how he comes back
rehabbing that as well so felder when
you look at this offense what do you
have your eyes on right now for kyle
murray
so we already talked about romeo dubs on
this show right we love him we love what
he's able to do on the field we'd love
his burner mentality and the ability as
a tall big wide receiver to still play
through contact so we love that uh he's
super special obviously coming out of
nevada his ability to get open find
himself open i think is interesting i
think he's someone that could be there
for them when they pick a little bit
later i think the interesting part for
me is going to be that tight end spot
you mentioned max williams was going
down with the injury do we need to back
that up do we need to fix this are we
going to carry three tight ends this
year or four tight ends of this year so
i'm going to go to a guy i know you like
and i want to give you a shot to talk
about because we couldn't slide them
into the tight end section so we
squeezed them in here but let's go to
isaiah likely from coastal carolina as a
guy who maybe he's a fix for them a
little bit later as a pro as a
developmental prospect that they can
grow into a bigger role
oh and he fits this offense perfectly
you look at where they're picking 87th
overall right there in round three that
is isaiah likely territory and you see
the downfield juice here and he brought
it up with romeo dubs not just to get
vertical but the the catch radius he's
got long arms and big hands and isaiah
likely fits that mold at the tight end
position where he's an athlete and can
run the seam and you can throw him these
he can chip and then stay underneath for
a catch and run screen
arizona's offense obviously is very
creative under cliff kingsbury this is
the type of tight end they like they
don't want somebody that's an in line
plotting along just going to sit there
and block all day they want somebody
that can offer a lot in the passing game
and isaiah likely is a great fit for
there he was tremendously productive
over there coastal carolina we got
thanos junior saying cards have to go
corner to me a lot of wide receivers in
la to cover hey we didn't do pick 23 for
a reason 23 can be offensive line
territory it can be corner trent
mcduffie felder and i looking deeper in
this draft at 55-87
for uh the cards moving on to the niners
their first pick is at 61. no rounder in
this draft because of the trey lance
trade last year they also have pick uh
93 in the top 100 as well so the niners
are going to be
bargain shopping like crazy but pick 61
is not bargain shopping felder i want to
start with jalen petrie i think this
team needs a safety that can come down
play in the box play the slot be
physical run with running backs in the
flats he showed at baylor he can do all
those things he did he was one of the
best one-on-one cover guys at the senior
bowl you see the hands there to make a
play on the football the downhill speed
is tremendous the niners can get
extremely creative with petrie they
still need a back end player they've
lost a couple of free agency and
injuries over the years i love petrie's
see ball get ball attitude for that
baylor defense
well yeah i mean at some point you still
have to have a guy that can track down
kyler murray right like
you you have to like you're going to
have to have someone that could that can
get to him and so i love the petrie pick
i think obviously his ability to play in
man but also the way he works in zone we
saw it right there that final part of
that clip his ability to fire and target
to get downhill to go make a play play
through a block is important i think
he's better going forward than backwards
and i don't think that's a knock on him
i think it's it's a testament to what he
does really well so you scheme that up
and you make it work for you uh i'm
gonna go um i'm gonna go a little deeper
in the draft we're gonna go cam jergens
right the uh nebraska place center do
you think he plays center in the nfl is
this guy gonna end up being ultimately a
guard
i think he's a center belter i think
he's going to come in and be a zone
center with that movement ability right
away and i like where your head's at
here pick 93 could be the sweet spot for
cam jergens in a great scheme fit for
him
no i i think it's interesting i love
that i think he can help you at guard
early if you're happy with your center
options but he has the ability to me to
fit those three interior positions until
he becomes your full-time starter at
center which again we talk about scheme
versatility player versatility all the
time and i think that's what you get
with him i think that's an interesting
element and i think it's something
because he's played
he's played a lot of football i think
that's the element that you're gonna get
as a guy that understands what's
happening and if he can help you out at
that three those three court guard
center guard if he can help you out of
those three now you've got someone that
is he has value on as you mentioned that
53-man roster
i saw david shepard in the comments
saying cair elam is my guy for the
niners
sorry there david shepard he's gonna go
in the top 40 picks in this draft the
niners would have to move up from 61 to
get him but i like where your head's at
thinking cornerback physical press kind
of player all right let's close this out
here felder with the rams nobody bargain
shops like the rams they use all the
premium picks to go get nfl superstars
and they say our scouts will find guys
outside the top 100. their first pick
builder is at 105 and then 142 175 and
then the rest of the picks are all
outside the top 200. i know you got two
sleeper-ish one player big time sleeper
here the other one's a name we've known
for a long time but i might not be as
drafted as highly as we thought so what
are you looking at here for the rams on
both sides of the ball
so we're going to start with darian
kindred i mean this guy
there was a time when he was at clemson
that he was legitimately thought of as a
possible first rounder right and so
obviously he transfers to georgie he's
being there making a play uh wins a
national championship in georgia
i think he won a national championship
at clemson as well like this guy played
a lot of football big time football and
was effective in it
but
something
no you know what no why am i doing this
connor you tell me tell me why he's
fallen off so hard from the nfl's
viewpoint
yeah you know it's a tough go of it for
darien kendrick number one he had some
off-field troubles that ultimately led
to his transfer and not you transfer to
georgia that's that's not a bad gig
right there so he's had some off-field
troubles that scouts are trying to get
through uh i think the other thing here
is felder
man
how do you go out and run a 47940 as a
cornerback
i don't that's not what he looks like on
film i've seen him show recovery speed
i'm not saying he's 4-3 i'm not saying
he's 4-4 i'm not even saying he's a 4-5
player but
this is a guy that in coverage does not
look like he's running like a linebacker
or a tight end and so it goes back to
your point felder we just had this
conversation with jalen weidemeyer but
for wydermeyer it's just all in the now
the football with kendrick there was
off-field stuff
what have you been doing do you not know
how to run the 40 what's going on here
because you are a good football player
so what is happening here
that is the question scouts and teams
need to answer on darion kendrick
yeah i'm i'm very curious to see where
he ends up but this could be a real
value pick because he's someone once you
get him in that building once you get
him around the rest of those players in
that locker room he's going to rise to
the occasion he was not a slouch at
georgia he was not as welch at clemson
this guy can play and the other guy i'm
gonna go we're gonna go deeper in the
draft right let's go to lucida smith oh
yeah and
this is someone who i will never forget
this
we were in atlanta and he was playing
tight end
and we were like what is this guy with
this weird body doing absolutely
destroying every defensive back
ultimately he grows into a guard but he
certainly is someone that can help you
on that offensive line
he really can and it's been a it's been
a good process for him because he got to
go to the senior he got the senior bowl
invite uh he carries his weight kind of
like a grizzly bear right felder where
you look at it everything's just so
thick from the top to bottom where you
like the anchor and when he gets his
hands on you the grip strength you're
gonna go places so with him i look at a
baltimore right a drive blocking scheme
a place that you know where he can use
that power utilize that power on the
rams inside runs can he utilize that
power can it be a depth piece for your
offensive line that has gotten older has
gotten hurt has lost some players over
the year where you need to be in that
bargain aisle and say can we find plus
starters in rounds four and five so i
like where your head's at felder you're
looking at guys that have been super
productive at the college level
for a long time both of them so let's
dive into the comments here before we
close out the show it's been a fun one
today this is wide receivers felder and
i can talk about all day long a really
loaded class all right let's get back in
here
alonzo soto says with the ram success
giving up high picks is that the reason
so many teams are giving up their first
rounders this year
felder are you are you a believer in
trading all your picks for proven talent
or do you think rosters can still be
built through the draft
i i think you can still it depends on
who your coach and who your gm are i
think you can still build a roster
through the draft and it's the whole
quote unquote trust the process
situation but the reality of it is the
rams and i think there's
there's it's it's kind of twofold right
it's their willingness to pay
their willingness to have budget players
at other spots that most teams would
feel uncomfortable with
and then
i guess threefold they're in la like
it's it's that's another part like
whether it's guys coming home or guys
that are enjoying living in l.a or guys
whose families want to live in la like
there's that other element to it i don't
know that everybody can follow that
model i don't think everyone can follow
that model and i think
that's the part that's going to be
interesting is who attempts to like if
you're green bay
you can't do this
if you're minnesota you can't do this if
you're the carolina panthers you can't
do this
um i mean the panthers probably could
afford to do it tepper's a billionaire
but they won't do it and so i think that
teams still have to focus on building
through the draft
yeah i think you're right felder it is
so location based not every team is
going to go out there and convince
pricey veterans uh come play here ring
chase we'll pay you all of those things
it's so team based that
you know it's really tough all right so
we have a funny one here from esco said
the rams are drafting for their kick
coverage team
on day three there's a lot more of that
going on than you think and i think
we'll close out with that one because
that is uh that's a top flight comment
belder
what a show today and it just goes to
show you when the draft coverage is
actually going on there are going to be
a ton of wide receivers and tight ends
coming off the board on days two and
three
yeah i'm looking forward to it a lot of
guys coming off the board we're gonna
get to show a lot of really good
highlights that aren't just low angle
footage of a lineman from a school no
one's ever heard of so this is gonna be
really fun
all right that's it for our wide
receivers in tight ends preview you know
the deal by now though the draft is on
the horizon and we are live in the
bleacher report app live on bleacher
reports youtube at 1pm every single
thursday that is 1pm eastern time shout
out to the comment section it's been
incredible you've been filling it up
with great stuff for connor rogers from
michael felder see you same time same
place
next week
[Music]
you
[Music]
you